This NASA animation shows what the US space agency expects to happen...
...when the Curiosity rover completes its nine - month journey to Mars.
A team of scientists has already selected the landing site:...
...the foot of a mountain within a deep, 150 kilometer - wide depression called Gale Crater.
After the parachute deploys, engines will start for a powered descent.
Curiosity will be lowered on cables.
And the rocket pack will blast off to an area where it will not affect the rover's chemical analysis equipment.
Curiosity is the size of a car and has 17 cameras.
The rover can use its drill to pulverize rocks...
...and its robotic arm to collect powder samples.
It then drops the samples into its own instruments for further analysis.
The goal is to learn if Gale Crater ever had environmental conditions that could have supported microbial life.
The mountain that is located within Gale Crater will yield plenty of information about the planet's evolution...
...because each layer of rock contains clues.
Curiosity and its spacecraft components are being assembled and undergoing final testing at the Kennedy Space Center in Florida.
It is said to launch in November or December.
Suzanne Presto, VOA News.